Thank You Jessica and thanking everyone
for attending this webinar this is the
first webinar of a series of three where
we will be looking at different aspects
of cell death in this session I will
talk to you about the different tools
available to study cell viability and
proliferation and to decide which are
say is most suitable for your
experimental setting while it is
important to look at cell viability on
one hand it is essential before doing
any cell based assay to assess whether
the cells you are going to use are
healthy and the reason for this is to
ensure that the results obtained from
the experiment are both reliable and
reproducible so starting your experiment
with healthy cells will help you to
optimize and standardize cell culture
conditions to avoid experimental
artifacts resulting from unhealthy cells
and to improve the accuracy of your
results on the other hand assessment of
viability is also a simple and low-cost
method to measure the effects of the
stimuli in culture cells allowing you to
spend more time and money in more
complicated downstream studies this ro
represents the ballas the balance of
life and death that cells are subjected
to cells will generally proliferate and
abide and at some point during the cell
cycle the cells will be subjected to
stresses stimuli which can be endogenous
like for instance a cell replication
defect or exogenous light drug treatment
if the cell can not repair and overcome
this stress then cells will die and
cells can die in several ways and
apoptosis represents a specific and
control type of cell death and sometimes
there is a confusion between viability
and apoptosis assays and in this stable
we try to summarize and clarified what
these assays are so cell by ability are
assess how healthy the cells are whereas
apoptotic assays look at how the cells
which we already know are not in a
healthy state are dying cell viability
assays generally detect markers of
cellular activity and they can be used
to optimize cell culture conditions that
we just mentioned or to intend to ensure
that the cells are happy before any
further study or treatment on the other
hand apoptotic assays the tag markers
are are activated only upon cell death
and I'll specifically use when we want
to detect by which mechanisms the cells
are dying it is very important to
understand that cell viability and
apoptosis assays are not exclusive by
complementary
before we use an upper ptosis assay we
will need to use a viability assay
because before we try to look at how the
cells are doing we have to make sure how
many cells are dead and if our initial
sample was in good condition before the
experiment started otherwise our results
will not be true so apoptosis assays and
other cell markers will be covered in
our next webinar session so I will
forgive now on by ability assays when we
talk about studying cell viability we
are mainly referring to the ability of a
cell to maintain or recover its
viability after cell injury as well as
determining how cells are before and
after stressful stimuli researchers
generally use viability assays as a
common name when talking about viability
proliferation and cytotoxicity and
although these terms are very
interchangeable indeed as we will show
later on the webinar they refer to
slightly different things cell
proliferation assays are used to monitor
the growth rate of a population or to
detect specific daughter cells in a
growing population on the other hand
cytotoxicity assays are used to
determine the number of lives on death
sells in a population after treatment so
these definitions are not mutually
exclusive and usually interchangeable as
we just said and you will see that
sometimes the same assay is used to
study both proliferation and
cytotoxicity so let's look now in more
detail at viability and cytotoxicity
essays which for clarity we will just
refer from now on as viability assays so
by ability assays can roughly be divided
into three types one it's what we say
called
the cellular metabolic activity assay
which is based on the modifications
generally by reduction or for a specific
dye by cellular or mitochondrial enzymes
another type if the site Allah sees or
leakage assay which is based on the fact
that some dyes can only enter or scape
cells when the membranes are no longer
intact a slightly different type of
assay is cell cycle assay which allows
the visualization of the cell cycle
profile so how does the metabolic
activity as I work the detector molecule
is added to the Culture Media and then
enter the live cells inside the cell
this detector molecule or dye is
generally modified in the cytosol of the
mitochondria so that it becomes
fluorescent or changes color and then
this change can be detected either by
microplate reader which can be
fluorescence or absorbance or by flow
cytometry so here's a representation of
how we visualize the readout when they
die is added to the culture if the cell
is s all dying the enzymes are not
functional anymore and there will be
lower or no signal so for cellular
metabolic activity assays a higher
signal denote live cells whereas a lower
signal means dying
or depth south so here you can see a
couple of examples on the upper panel
you can see Jacobs cells treated with
increasing concentrations of the stars
following during four hours stars
pouring is a protein kinase inhibitor
which is known for inducing cell death
and it's commonly used as a positive
control the viability of the cells was
measured after four hours with our
mitochondria viability stain where the
indicator died is modified by
mitochondrial enzymes the oxidation
products can be measured by absorbance
which produces a pink color or by
fluorescence in the lower panel you can
see how our colorimetric cell
cytotoxicity assay which has a similar
working principle was used to assess the
viability of the neuroblastoma cell line
si si v the data highlighted here
suggest that dopamine reduces cell
survival in a sci-fi cells independently
of alpha-synuclein presence a slight
variation of the metabolic a say it's
the LDH cytotoxicity assay this assay
detects the presence of LD h the light
ad hydrogenous enzyme in the cell
culture medium LD h is retaining the
cytoplasmic in viable cells but it leaks
into the culture medium when the cells
are dying and the membranes are
disrupted in this case the probe is not
able to enter the cells so this signal
is only produced when the LD h is
released into the medium so i'm now
going to talk you about this ayat allah
sees as a so how these are se works the
principle is a slightly different
depending on whether we use an
impermeable or a permeable dye an
impermeable diet will enter the cell
only
when the cell membrane is broken
and then we'll diffuse into the nuclei
and become fluorescent when it comes
links to the DNA this type of assay is
not compatible with fixation that the
succession process itself affects the
integrity of the cell membranes so here
you can see again the representation of
how we visualize the readout if we add
to the cell culture media a dye which is
impermeable and that means that cannot
enter the cell if the membrane is intact
we will not see any signal in live cells
however if the cells are death the
amendment will be broken and the dye
will be able to enter and spend a new
place so therefore in this case a higher
signal the nose stem cells whereas a
lower signal means live cells if we use
a permeable dive for this assay the
working principle is almost the opposite
of the one we have just seen so in this
case the dye can diffuse freely through
the intact plasma membrane into the
cytosol but is then generally modified
by s2 races to become fluorescent
because the fluorescent molecule kind of
diffuse back to the membrane this type
of assay is actually compatible with
fixation so you can see here that when
we use a permeable dye we will get a
higher signal in life cells on the
contrary as we've just mentioned and you
can see in the left side when we use an
impermeable dye we will get a high
signal in the death cells and here you
can see a couple of example for each of
this type of dice on the Apple panel it
shows your good cells treated with
increasing concentrations of a tappa
site which is a topoisomerase 2
inhibitor in this case we have used our
life and death cell assay to assess the
number of life and death cells at the
same time the live cell died which is a
green dye is membrane permeability the
live cells
what is retained and becomes
florescent the death cell dye which is a
red dye is only able to enter cells that
have disrupted membranes so this is a
very simple and efficient method to look
at both life and themselves at the same
time in the same population because this
assay uses a dead cell dye is not
compatible with fixation in the lower
panel you can see your dead cells
treated with the Stars pouring or heat
and stained with a green viability life
this product in particular is compatible
with formaldehyde fixation so I will
talk briefly now about cell cycle ah
sighs you're all familiar with the cell
cycle phases so just to remind you
quickly that cells have different DNA
content depending on which phase of the
cell cycle they're at so to look at the
cell cycle profile cells are stained
with fluorescent dyes that bind to the
double-stranded DNA and then are
generally sorted in a flow cytometry
cell cycle profile from a healthy cell
population in culture will then look
like this two main pigs can be on surf
the left one which is called the g1 pic
contains the cells found in the g1 state
which are generally the majority of the
cells in the population the other pic is
called g2m and will contain the cells
that are ready to enter mitosis or in
mitosis in between these two pigs
we found the replicating cells which are
in S phase
sometimes left of the g1 peak we can
find what is called the sub G one
population and these are the cells that
have lost some DNA which is then an
indication of cell death it is a quick
way to visualize cell death cells but I
will talk about this sub G one
population in more detail in our
following webinar so here you can see
how reduce propidium iodide to stain
HeLa cell
that have been exposed to different
conditions the group in the control
group which is shown on panel a shows
the typical profile expected on healthy
cells so a big g1 pig and then small G
to M peak treatment with high
concentration of time eating which is
shown in panel B interrupts the
deoxynucleotide metabolism pathway and
blocks DNA replication so as the cells
are not able to progress most of them
will be arrested in the g1 s peak on the
other hand
Nichola sole treatment which is shown in
panel C he named its microtubule
polymerization which causes the cell to
arrest in mitosis as the metaphase the
spindles cannot be formed so here we see
that most of the cells are found in the
g2 empik I will now introduce
proliferation assays proliferation
assays looked at how the cells in the
population are actively dividing because
of this proliferation assays are
commonly used as viability assays
because after all a dividing cell is
definitely a viable cells there for
proliferation and viability assays are
often put in the same package and as I
mentioned many researchers will use
proliferation assays to measure by
ability as well I will discuss briefly
the different types of proliferation
assays which are detection of DNA
synthesis measuring cellular metabolic
activity dye delusion ASAE's and
staining of proliferation proteins
the first type I will talk about is the
assay based on detection of DNA
synthesis the most accurate cell
proliferation assay is there are eight
quantification of the newly synthesized
DNA strand by looking at the
incorporation of a deoxyribonucleoside
analog which is generally known as
simoleans analogues
this method can be used in multiple
platforms such as
immunohistochemistry Eliza or flow
cytometry and in this table you can see
the most common limiting analogs
commonly used by researchers the
original cell proliferation measurement
is based on the incorporation of
radioactive nuclei sites such as
saturated 'cimmanon into DNA this method
was devised in the 1950s when the use
and other active compounds was more
extended is highly used nowadays because
of the dangers of heart activity use and
although it was introduced about 40
years ago brdu is still probably the
most used and cited method to quantify
DNA synthesis the main limitations of
brdu
are the requirement of valuation steps
to facilitate the detection molecule
detection of the molecule by anty anty
brdu antibodies the denaturation can
affect also the cell morphology and it
limits the use with Co staining of
fluorescent proteins IDU and Ciardi you
are modifications of brdu
and the detection principle is also
based on antibodies the limitations are
the same ones also brdu however in
comparison to the other you these
analogues can be used together which
allows researchers to perform more
complex experiments edu which is
mentioned at the bottom of the table is
the youngest members of these analog
family in comparison with the previous
ones it does not rely on antibodies and
therefore does not require at an
iteration step the edu incorporated into
the new DNA strand can be detected by a
copper catalyzed reaction that uses a
fluorescent dye so here you can see a
couple of examples or have to use the
audit you to look at proliferation on
the top panel you can see the
proliferation
of three to three fibroblast measured by
using a brdu Eliza aside and you can see
how the increase in the signal
correlates with an increase in the
number of cells in the lower panel you
can see how brdu was used to visualize
proliferating cells in mountainous
intestinal tissue section by mr.
chemistry proliferation can also be
measured by looking at cellular
metabolic activity the working principle
of looking at cell a metabolic activity
has already been described in the by
bility section so I will not go into
detail here just to remind you that a
die gets modified by the activity of
intercellular enzymes and if the cell is
proliferating it will get a stronger
signal then can be detected by either
absorbance or fluorescence another
method to look at cell proliferation is
by dye dilution dye dilution assays are
based on membrane permanent fluorescent
dyes that are retained within the cells
through subsequent round of cell
divisions so as the cell divide the dye
is roughly equally divided into daughter
cells and as this divide the dye is then
diluted through our generations dye
dilution is analyzed by flow cytometry
which allows the visualization of the
fluorescent Peaks which in turn enables
the calculation of the number of
original dividing cells so here you can
see how it works the first generation of
cells which will be this stain cells
will show a highly fluorescent peak as
the cells delight
the intensity of the pig decreases
shifting the pig to the left and so on
and so on until the signal cannot be
detected so here you can see examples of
dye exclusion essays the top panel shows
your grid cells labeled with CF is e
which is one of the most commonly useful
for Asian diets and faculty was the
first one that was described so you can
see how the pig shift of the cell
division side place the main limitation
of CF is e is that it can be easily a
flux from the cell potentially leading
to a decrease in the fluorescent
independent of the proliferation rate
the lower panel shows your cut cells
label with our next generation site to
paint the proliferation reagent the
fluorescent of this reagent can be
detected for up to nine generations
after staining and does not suffer a
flux like CFS e also one of the
advantages of this diet is that it can
be available in multiple colors which
allows constraining with GFP so I will
now briefly cover how to study
proliferation by looking at
proliferating cells for printing
proteins there are some proteins that
are only expressed when cells are
proliferating and the most commonly
known and use are proliferation markets
at Keio 67 PCNA or MCM to the
proliferating proteins need to be
detected in a spatial temporal context
and the way to do that is by using
specific antibodies and tissue samples
these markers are mainly used for
clinical diagnostic and prognostic
studies and therefore are not really
suited to study a larger number of
samples
and I will just briefly mention and talk
to you about senescence so if you
remember the cell cycle diagram I show
you earlier in the webinar these are
cells that seem to be out of the typical
there are cells that seem to be out of
the typical cell cycle profile these are
the cells that are in growth our rest a
process which is generally known as key
essence growth or else can be either
reversible or irreversible we talked
about key essence when the growth of
rest phase is temporary and then can be
reverted to growth phase when there are
five variable conditions in the media
and in the surrounding area senescence
refers to a permanent growth arrest
where the cells remain metabolically
active but do not divide this phenomenon
was first described in fibroblasts in
culture in the maximum number of cell
divisions then a cell can undertake
before becoming senescence is called
hayflick limit senescence cells can be
refrigerated from proliferating cells by
having a flattened and large morphology
the carbon biological markers used to
the text in essence are generally
limited and not very specific so for
example increase expression of
intracellular or secreted proteins such
as p21 p16 il-6
phosphorylated p38 smurf 2 or PGM have
been cited in the literature as markers
to senescence this markers will
generally be used in combination with
one of the most established senescence
market which is the senescence
associated better galactosidase protein
this is a lysosomal hydrolase which
changes its optimal pH for activity when
the cells become senescent
shifting from ph4 to p8 six the staining
of beta galactosidase activity is based
on the transformation of the substrate
x-gal by the enzyme into a blue product
so now that we have reviewed all the
difference available we need to decide
which are we going to use and the answer
is really that it depends on what you
want to detect so let's say for instance
if you want to check how healthy you
cells are before starting an experiment
which is recommended as we mentioned at
the beginning of the webinar quick
staining using dyes like propidium
iodide or even trippin blue with a light
microscope and visualizing the cells
might be enough on the other hand
assessing viability or proliferation by
metabolic activity will allow you to
quantify the number of viable cells in
your sample if what you want to do is to
check the effect of a mycological
compounds or mutations that can have in
the cells you can look at viability and
quantify the number of viable or
enviable cells in comparison to their
treated control
similarly you can look at proliferation
or proliferation rate of the cells in
comparison to the untreated control or
you might want to look at the cell cycle
profile as these will allow you to check
whether a mutation or a compound for
example is affecting the cell cycle
progression you can also detect where
the cells are dying if there is an
increase on the subji one population if
you see a decrease on proliferation but
there is no direct increase in death
cells you might want to check whether
yourself have become senescent if you
want to monitor the effect the
pharmacological compounds or mutation
will have in a specific cell population
over a long period of time and at the
same time you want to monitor expression
of surface markers so for example dye
exclusion assay is probably the best
choice as it will allow you to do a con
staining with other intracellular or
extracellular markers and of course
apart from what you want to the tag
there are other considerations you have
to keep in mind the type of cell you're
studying might dictate the type of
viability or proliferation assay that
you can use are you using primary or
culture cells primary cells don't divide
as quickly as prote yourself and they
also tend to stop dividing earlier some
ass is like metabolic activity are
easier to perform in adherent cells
because they are generally done in a
96-well plate while alpha is performing
a flow cytometry are generally easier to
do with suspension cells or 3d cell
cultures for example will be more
difficult to stain than 2d cultures if
the model you are using has a defect in
mitochondrial dehydrogenases for example
it's best to avoid using metabolic
activity based assay since they require
these enzymes the type of
instrumentation that you have available
might also dictate the type of assay
that you can do for instance whether you
have a colorimetric or volumetric
microplate reader or the appropriate
filter for the plate reader or the flow
cytometry oil in the microscope if you
want to perform high-throughput readings
for example some asses like dye dilution
might not be suitable and there are
other factors to keep in mind when
choosing a viability of alliteration
assay because that's for instance the
cost of the assay where they fit the
total cost or the cost per assay
scalability how long is going to take
you and whether it gives you
the ability of multiplexing or not so
just to conclude this webinar I like to
run you through some of their key points
with cover today it is always best
practice to ensure that the cells you
are planning to use in an experiment are
healthy and viable to avoid having to
repeat the experiment later on cell
viability and proliferation assays are
often interchangeable and in the
majority of cases
Pannalal can be used for the same
purpose dye dilution proliferation
assays are best used when starting cells
over various generations while also can
be used to look at other cellular
markers such as GFP expressing proteins
cell cycle assays are best used when you
are expecting to see an effect on the
cell cycle progression and senescence
assays should be consider when cells in
culture are not dividing as expected or
when proliferation is reduced but there
is no increase in cell death but if
there's only one thing I want you to
remember today is in fact that the best
way to assess which are say you can use
to measure viability of proliferation
it's by thinking before you do the
experiment so what is the answer you
want to get what do you want to look at
so thank you very much for your
attention and I'm ready to answer any of
the questions we have received and
remember that you can keep sending
questions while I read out some of the
questions
so one of the questions we had is why
the main disadvantages of proliferation
metabolic gases um there's several
disadvantages and one is that because
these are phase depend on cellular
activity they can sometime give false
positives or fall negatives so for
instance um when cells suffer damage and
they start trying to overcome this
stress this January drip reflects on an
increase in mitochondrial activity to
try to get rid of the damage so it might
look when you especially when you're
using low concentrations of drugs that
there is an increasing proliferation and
it doesn't mean that the cells are
proliferating or being more viable is
just that the enzymes are more active so
it's something that you have to keep in
mind and on the other hand sometimes a
decrease for instance a medium
consumption of the medium or excessive
cell density tends to result in a
shutdown of the mitochondrial functions
and then this can lead to an
underestimation another of the questions
we have it's um when conducting
viability assays that's the length of
the length of time for which the cells
are in culture before treatment matter
there is when they are fitted into a
ninety six plate plate for determining
cytotoxicity effect and this is because
different cells have different during
times and is not fact it experiments but
the question is the answer is yes
probably because for instance as we just
as I've just said if you play yourself
you live them for a long time and then
the plate the well itself becomes very
dense this is going to affect your
viability and can also be again when
these cells are if you've played them
let's say if you just took the stock
from the liquid nitrogen or their
primary cells and they are fairly fresh
they are more likely to start
proliferating quicker they're becoming
at the end of their lifetime
another question that we have if you
want to determine sell that's right what
are the alternatives to Aldi age and
that is a very good question and
actually nil I might take dad offline
because I need to understand what do you
exactly mean but sell that's right
if what you mean is how quick they are
dying or actually what you want to
detect is compared to their control so
if it's a Y we'll follow that offline
and so I have a question vague and I see
a lot of papers using MTT as I mean to
measure viability of the cells in
culture in my opinion I think they are
looking at mitochondrial functions
rather than the entire cells I wish to
know your take on that and that is
actually completely correct as I just
mentioned MTT is based on the metabolic
activity of these generally
mitochondrial dehydrogenases or what
they're measuring is a cellular activity
where usually the reason why MTT or wc1
are generally uses viability is because
there is a correlation and of course
with any experiment you always have to
take it into the context that you doing
it it's always necessary to have a
control which you have untreated if
possible if you're looking for instance
and a drug try to use it with the
solvent and always have a positive
control so I think the reason why most
people we tend to use MTTs MTX or w1 is
because they give a quick readout about
the cells and because it allows to do it
in 96 or even in a 384 well plate it's a
very good point to looking very quickly
whether your cells are dying or not so I
think that's why it's a very personal
method
[Music]
another question that I have is when you
plan
availability I say do you have to start
sales overnight before adding the
compound not necessarily I think it
would depend on the type of media
because for instance reducing compounds
like dtt or ascorbic acid when they are
used together with things like empty tea
or wc1 they can cause interference so in
that case you might have to sort of
starve yourself if you starve yourself
you're more likely to create a stress so
then your cells are probably in that pre
stress status so I think then yourself
might not be in a healthy population so
my preference would say no but also
depends on the type of the compounds you
want to study obviously the best answer
in this case would be that half a look
at yourself overnight maybe do a pre
experiment without adding any compound
compared to a non starving cells and see
how they affect if you don't see any
short-term effect then I would say it
might depend but I would say my
preference is is not another question is
is there a number of tumbling is there
like a number of doubling times after
planting in 96-well plate to allow it
before treatment self cytotoxicity
assays and I don't think there is I
think the reason why researchers tend to
leave the plates overnight is just to
ensure that all the plates and all the
cells are attached to these I attach to
the bottom of the plate and some
protocols especially again with empty
TWC some of them will ask you to
aspirate yourself and then of course if
yourself haven't been fully attached
you'll lose them and some of them you
don't need to but then if they are not
fully attached you might get some
interference so I think that's why
generally they prefer method is to say
leave them overnight to ensure they have
been attached proper
to the bottom of the plate but it really
depends after you so there is a question
but it hasn't been fully returned so so
it um I told you mind sending it back
because I only got half of it so we have
another question in the meantime is
there propidium your life cell cycle is
sufficient to quantify the proportion of
cells in each state or is the BIDU
method preferable and the p.i method is
preferring the lab to simplicity and in
some sample preparation again I think it
depends and with many types of very
specific flow cytometry like the
psychics that will allow you to look in
the cells each specific cells so I think
they're looking at different stuff if
what you want to quantify is the
proportion of cells in different stage
icing API staining is probably the best
option but the brdu is telling you if
poly just telling you which cells are on
the DNA in which the DNA is replicating
for your bit early just looking at that
state of quantification if what you're
looking is proliferation itself then
definitely brdu
is better but if what you want to do is
just quantify the proportion of cells
into each state I would say API staining
is probably better so I have a question
saying I have opposing results with
tripping blue and LD HSA which should I
trust which dipper and blue also
decrease in LD in cell they're following
compound treatment but with LD h i saw
an increase on cell death i'm i think
again i'm maybe Michael we could take
this off offline and we could look into
more details I'm I think part of it LD h
again after all is a sort of metabolic
reading because what you're reading is
emit is the leakage of the LD h activity
and so you might be
over reading or under estimating in this
case you would be undressed
overestimating the cell death with three
plum blue what you might be doing is
actually if you if your cells are
already death and they're fragmented you
might be missing that so I will try to
follow you on that to get more specific
response so see that's right so
apologies I'm trying to read the small
print and another question is what's the
best assay to differentiate between
cytotoxic and cytostatic effect yes we
haven't talked about cytostatic effect
because many of the researchers they
only interested to looking at the
cytotoxic effect but things like low
nocturnal genic a safe which is
princessy crystal violet abstaining of
growing colonies of cells over a long
period of time is one of the best ones
and that's because you can kind of look
at yourself growing over a long period
of times and then stain them afterwards
and that helps you to I don't you can
see the long-term difference between
reversible kind of cell death arrest and
then whether the cells are actually
dying so requesting some we were missing
before is when you're treating cells
with different drug concentrations the
differences in culture media provided by
the diluted drugs can affect the data it
could be I mean culture media things
like phenol red sometimes interferes
with some colorimetric assays and again
because colorimetric assay what it does
is measure the changes in color and the
absorbance the absorbers might be
affected if there might with them some
Pacific some small precipitates or
contaminations in the South so that
could be it could actually affect or in
this case obviously after a metric assay
might be preferred if you're expecting
some interferences